mais d'abord faut-il réinventer le pass
sanitaire l'assouplir en fonction de nos
lieux de loisirs en fonction des
départements et le prolonger si oui
jusqu'à quand le sénat tranche ces
questions aujourd'hui c'est mathias
les sénateurs attendaient de pied ferme
le 11e projets de loi liés à l'urgence
sanitaire à l'ordre du jour notamment la
prolongation du pass sanitaires une
mesure préventive pour le gouvernement
qui souhaite pouvoir y avoir recours
jusqu'au 31 juillet prochain selon
philippe bas rapporteur du texte au
palais du luxembourg cela serait une
atteinte à la démocratie
et quand on donne l'autorisation au
gouvernement on ne peut lui donner que
pour une durée limitée
nous n'avons même pas une suspicion
particulière pour ce gouvernement ou
pour un autre
nous disons s'il y avait un autre
gouvernement d'ailleurs il y en aura un
autre au mois de mai nous ne le
connaissons pas est-ce qu'on va
aujourd'hui lui donner des pouvoirs
alors que nous ne connaissons pas
largement modifié par la commission des
lois du sénat le texte prévoit d'abord
de ne pas prolonger l'utilisation du
passani terre au delà du 28 février 2022
ensuite de ne plus y avoir au cours dans
les départements où la couverture
vaccinale dépasse les 75 % soit près de
sept collectivités territoriales sur dix
en france métropolitaine une réécriture
qui ne fait pas l'unanimité mais qui
bénéficie de soutiens en dehors de la
majorité sénatoriale
les aménagements qui lui ont été
apportés ont conduit à ce qu'un certain
nombre d'entre nous ils soient
finalement favorable cela étant chacun
se décidera suivant la liberté de vote
qui caractérise le rds le débat qui
n'est que très peu de chances de pencher
en faveur des sénateurs fera l'objet
d'une commission mixte paritaire entre
les deux chambres le mercredi 3 novembre
prochain moins de deux semaines avant la
fin de l'état d'urgence sanitaire
actuellement fixée au 15 novembre
et on débat ici aussi dans ce sens
publique sur l'extension des spas
sanitaire je présente mes invités claude
malhuret bonsoir soit venu vous êtes
sénateur de l'allier président du groupe
les indépendants et médecin quand même
important de le rappeler pour un débat
sur sur ce thème yann chanterelle
bonsoir aujourd'hui vous êtes sénateur
socialiste des français de l'étranger
thibault mercier bonsoir soit mieux vaut
aussi avocat au barreau de paris vous
êtes président du cercle droits et
libertés laetitia cuba éditorialiste
politique moi ça me côté bonsoir
laetitia merci de d'être la prolonger le
pass sanitaire jusqu'au mois de juillet
c'est trop long dit la droite
majoritaire au sénat mais elle est assez
divisés claude malhuret j'ai
l'impression c'est ce qui ressortait des
débats de la deux de cet après midi oui
c'est pas tout à fait ça c'est pas
prolonger le pass sanitaire jusqu'en
juillet ses données au gouvernement la
possibilité de le prolonger si l'année
si la situation d'impôts mais donc on
n'est pas en train de dire aux votes sur
le fait que le passager est prolongée
jusqu'en juillet on espère que
l'épidémie va se terminer et dans un
mois dans deux mois dans trois mois je
ne sais pas quand les chiffres quand le
conseil scientifique dira on peut s'en
passer quand je vois le gouvernement ne
peut prendre la décision d'arrêter le
passé et j'espère bien quand on arrêtera
avant le 31 juillet mais vous êtes vous
avez vu ce qui se passe en ce moment
l'épidémie flambent dans tous les pays
voisins de la france et elle remonte
légèrement en france on est dans une
situation enviable parce qu'on est sans
doute le pays avec l'espagne ne plus
vacciner au monde mais ça n'empêche pas
qu'il y ait un nouveau variant et c'est
donc c'est une possibilité ça ne veut
pas dire du tout que le passé un test
durera jusqu'au 31 juillet oui avec
l'hypothèse d'une clause de revoyure ou
en tout cas d'un rendez vous en février
et souriant alors ça c'est ce que c'est
ce que va sans doute voter la majorité
du sénat aujourd'hui le problème c'est
que le sénat et de l'assemblée c'est que
le parlement ne siège pas de février de
fin février à fin juin et alors qu'est
ce qu'on fait pendant ce temps là donc
le laisser là raisons pour lesquelles le
gouvernement propose de
maintenir cette autorisation jusqu'au 31
juillet moi ça me paraît normal parce
que il faut bien trouver une solution si
une épidémie recommencer tout bien que
le gouvernement comme il l'a fait
d'ailleurs
il ya quelques mois le décide quitte à
revenir ensuite devant le parlement pour
le faire valider alors sur cette
question du calendrier parce qu'après il
ya beaucoup d'autres éléments a détaillé
je voudrais entendre vous vos prises de
position et yann chanterelle pour
commencer oui bah déjà je pense qu'en
tant que parlementaire c'est vraiment un
régime d'exception déjà qu'on a un train
de repousser aux calendes grecques
jusqu'au 31 juillet je pense que
collectivement nous pouvons trouver que
ça inacceptable moi même je suis
sénateur des français établis hors de
france donc il ya des jeux je connais
d'autres pays d'autres régimes
démocratiques chuterait moi même je
viens d'un pays qui est le canada ou qui
est un régime parlementaire et ces
choses là n'ont pas lieu d'être je pense
les gens sont très choqués des gens qui
nous regardent qui ne sont pas en france
sont très choqués à quel point le
gouvernement piétine en permanence dans
ce pays les droits du parlement et
quelque part n'accepte pas le débat
d'une dizaine de
deux textes différents qui sont venus au
parlement mais pourquoi on était enfin
consulter à chaque fois en fait la
question c'est pourquoi le repousser au
31 juillet c'est quoi la raison pourquoi
on leur pose au 31 juillet qu'on veut
pas aller au mois de février la raison
on la connaît très bien c'est parce que
monsieur emmanuel macron le président de
la république ne souhaite pas qu'on
aborde ce débat collectivement au moment
de la campagne présidentielle tout
simplement et je pense que au niveau
démocratique c'est important aussi que
ces questions là soit au coeur du débat
présidentiel soit au coeur des questions
les habille nos compatriotes français et
les parlementaires qui sont les
représentants du peuple français sont le
mieux à même également de pouvoir donner
leur opinion pourquoi devrait-on
suspendre tout débat toute discussion
d'un sujet aussi grave aussi important
pendant la campagne présidentielle
alors lille à vis de thibault mercier et
puis claude malhuret vous pourrez
répondre globalement aux collectivement
après je suis assez d'accord avec ce qui
vient d'être dit à ma gauche et ça me
donne l'opportunité de rebondir sur un
point qui n'est pas abordée pour la
future présidentielle c'est notre
désamour pour la liberté en général en
france et 7 cette crise nous a bien
montré que finalement dans ce dans les
mesures qui était prise c'était pas
seulement le gouvernement qui venaient
nous imposer des choses mais c'était il
y avait aussi une certaine demande de la
part des concitoyens de nos concitoyens
qui ne recherchait plus donc cette
liberté mais plutôt une sécurité à tout
prix une recherche du confort et qui a
tendance à nous paralyser et comme on
recherche le confort finalement on est
prêt à déléguer notre liberté à la fois
au gouvernement et aussi à nos
représentants nous nos représentants qui
n'exerce pas forcément d'ailleurs leurs
prérogatives de manière
votre facile vertige crois qu'il dénonce
carrément le principe du pass sanitaires
oui bien sûr puisque en fait dans cette
dans cette philosophie du pass sanitaire
il ya quelque chose d'assez malsain
c'est le fait de devenir conditionner
notre liberté désormais non plus à notre
citoyenneté du qu'allons nous étions
français est libre puisque nous avions
cette citoyenneté désormais c'est selon
votre état de santé bon et nous avons
surtout peur dé manière dont il sera
utilisé à l'avenir puisque ça devait
jusqu'au 15 novembre là on nous le
promet la possible du site utilisé
jusqu'au 31 juillet 2022 quelle sera la
prochaine à respectivement on y
reviendra ça n'arrive pas si souvent
mais je vais vous dire ce que je pense
moi j'ai plutôt l'impression d'avoir
récupéré de la liberté grâce au pass
sanitaire si je compare à la période
déconfinement que j'étais bouquet chez
moi bref mais ce n'est que mon avis
claude malhuret vous m'enlevez mauvais
goût on a même prévu mais bon d'abord
sur le principe du pass sanitaires c'est
une évidence
moi je vais dans mon département vous
allez dans la rue vous rencontrez vos
amis etc les français ont bien compris
que le passé ni terre ça n'était pas une
contrainte c'était d'une liberté c'est
pour ça qu'on a pu réouvrir des tas de
choses qu'on n'aurait pas pu réouvrir
autrement et par conséquent aujourd'hui
on sait on nous avait prédit que ce
serait épouvantable qu'on n'avait pas le
mettre en place que tout le monde allait
s'engueuler avec tout le monde que ça se
passe très bien dont manifestement nos
compatriotes sont très et ils ont raison
de mon point de vue il ya trois raisons
pour lesquelles l'épidémie a été
aujourd'hui juguler en france un taux de
vaccination extrêmement bon les gestes
barrière qui sont appliquées et le pass
and i ter qui a d'ailleurs permis de
multiplier la vaccination est donc sur
le principe évidemment moi je suis tout
à fait pour le passé ni terre et pour le
prolonger tant qu'on n'est pas sûr que
l'idée me ne sera pas atteindre
deuxièmement sur le procès fait au
gouvernement de passer par dessus le
parlement etc vous l'avez dit vous-même
ça fait onze fois depuis le début
insérons démis 11 fois que le
gouvernement devient demander au
parlement l'autorisation de poursuivre
dans les autres pays européens ou en
tout cas dans plusieurs pays européens
le gouvernement n'a même pas jugé
nécessaire de le faire il prend les
décisions par décret et ils nous passent
mal devant le parlement et on vient
faire le reproche au gouvernement
français de sauter par dessus le
parlement alors qu'il a consultés on
soit en février 2000 nous avons pris la
décision d'autoriser l'état d'urgence en
février 20 2021 jusqu'au 31 décembre
2021 il s'agit aujourd'hui de demander
une prolongation février
à descendre ça fait dix mois et ont eux
été on l'a parfaitement acceptée on s'en
souvient même plus le parlement a voté
l'autorisation de 10 mois et maintenant
on nous demande une prolongation de huit
mois et demi et on nous dit c'est à
cause de la présidentielle c'est parce
que ma qu'on veut pas en entendre parler
ben je suis désolé il l'a déjà demandé
on lui a déjà et on n'a pas sauté on l
aime donc je vois pas de je vois pas ou
pour ces deux raisons je vois pas
aujourd'hui en quoi on peut critiquer le
gouvernement et lætitia vous nous parler
de la stratégie du présent arrêt public
dans un instant mais je pense que l'un
et l'autre vous voulez répondre et il
veut commencer yann chanterelle vous en
faites ce qu'il faut vraiment pas
s'accoutumer à des états d'exception je
pensais le danger il est vraiment là il
faut pas que l'exceptionnel devienne la
règle et là le risque il est vraiment
grand que justement quelque chose qui
était exceptionnel et votre gouvernement
lui même je peux reprendre les propos de
certains ministres qui dirait qu'ils
disaient devant la représentation
nationale qu'il n'y aurait jamais de
passes sanitaires il y en a eu 1 et
désormais vous voulez le projet le
prolonger pratiquement advitam eternam
ça n'est pas possible ça état
d'exception à un moment donné il va
vraiment la beauté à un moment donné un
moment donné il va falloir quand même en
sortir et il suffit d'analyser vous
parler des autres pays européens
d'autres pays ce qu'il ya beaucoup de
pays qui adoptent le pass alternant ya
des pays qui ne l'adoptent pas qu'ils
ont des taux de vaccination beaucoup
plus important que le nôtre je peux vous
en citer d'un très grand nombre donc de
dire que de dire que le pass à la traîne
ça soit forcément le 6 avr déjà il ya
plusieurs applis ya plusieurs provinces
au sein du canada où c'est le cas et il
ya beaucoup plus de vaccination jamais
vous donnez des pays européens la
tendance et d'espagne sont les deux pays
européens n'est plus vaccinée les plus
les plus sont plus que ce que la langue
que leader nous passâmes
sanitaires à partir du moment que vous
attendez à vendre je
sais qui et c'est évidemment de gens
vaccinés mais je n'ai évidemment que il
faut que ce soit temporaire ce sera un
temps fort ces fentes c'est temporaire
en fonction de l'épidémie quand
l'épidémie sera terminée ou qu'elle ne
soit que ce sera presque terminés plus
dangereuse on le supprime mais au moment
où les billets me remonte dans tous les
pays européens est un peu en france
c'est le moment ou jamais de le garder
le problème - pour monsieur le sénateur
le problème c'est qu'avec une
philosophie pareil on sera en permanence
en état de vigilance est d'ailleurs
olivier ferrand l'a dit devant le
parlement que la loi ne s'appelaient
plus l'état d'urgence une loi d'état
d'urgence mais une loi de vigilance
sanitaire donc désormais cet état de
vigilance pour un qui pousse le principe
de précaution à l'extrême permet de
restreindre nos libertés en permanence
quasiment et à chaque fois on nous dit
que ça va être temporaires et notamment
la justification de ce pass sanitaires
c'était la vaccination on voit que la
vaccination a été un succès en france
que vous l'avez dit vous-même je crois
que c'est 50 ou 55 millions de français
vaccinés 90% de la population vaccinable
est vacciné et désormais on nous dit
qu'il faut encore continuer avec ce pass
sanitaires et continuer dans un régime
d'exception qui a qui pose de sacs de
sérieux problèmes démocratiques ce que
vous ne voulez pas voir et d'ailleurs
quand vous dites qu'on est venu vous
demander 11 fois l'autorisation devant
la représentation nationale c'est vrai
mais il faut quand même jugé et la façon
dont ça a été fait à chaque fois avec
des lois qui sont passés en procédure
accélérée
il ya même un sénateur qui dès qu'ils
dénoncé en juillet dernier qu'on lui
avait mis un pistolet sur la tempe pour
voter et même jean jacques urvoas qui
est l'ancien garde des sceaux a dit que
les sénateurs étaient des bâtisseurs de
ruines quand ils acceptaient de
travailler dans quelles conditions dans
de telles conditions vous êtes avocat
vous savez bien que la procédure
accélérée c'est aujourd'hui 95 soit sur
100 les lois le dénoncer et montrer aux
français que finalement et le parlement
ne viendrait ce que je voudrais vous
dire on s'habitue à vis d'un régime
d'exception mais les lois sont tellement
compliquées et celle qu'on est en train
de voter c'est surtout un vrai écrit par
la commission c'est encore plus pire que
tout les gens n'y comprennent plus rien
j il faut quand même préciser que nous
ne sommes pas en état d'urgence que nous
ne sommes plus en état d'urgence aide
aux gens ce qui me paraît assez simple
et on est à dire que nous sommes dans un
régime où le gouvernement s'il le
souhaite peut déclarer en cas d'urgence
l'état de l'état d'urgence mais il ya
plusieurs mois que nous ne sommes plus
on est alors il faut quand même que les
français le sachent donc arrêtons de
dire qu'on est sur un état d'exception
qui se perpétue laetitia la quelle carte
joue
emmanuel macron avec le pass sanitaire
par rapport à l'opinion une fois n'est
pas coutume dans cette pandémie il joue
l'opinion publique thomas c'est très
clair alors je vous ai relevé un
verbatim lu dans le parisien d'un off
alors le problème c'est que c'est un
anonyme mais c'est un proche de
l'exécutif et outiller la date du 31
juillet n'est pas un sujet pour les
français qui l'ont tous accepté sauf une
frange marginale de la population donc
on comprend bien que le gouvernement dit
écoutez c'est bien qu'il y ait un débat
démocratique comme on l'a ce soir parce
qu'il faut des garde-fous évidemment
pour ne pas qu'on bascule dans un régime
liberticide mais mais les français ont
compris l'utilité d'un tel passé de
telles mesures et d'ailleurs oliviero
l'a dit lui même quand il était
auditionné mardi devant les sénateurs
écoutez le on n'a pas suffisamment de
recul à ce stade pour pouvoir nous
priver d'un outil qui est fonctionnel
qui est bien acceptée par les gens qui
est très bien accepté par les gens avec
le recul mais c'est le sénateur bassi
est très bien accepté par les gens
aujourd'hui je les enquêtes d'opinion
montrent que les français sont
favorables aux pass sanitaire dans leur
majorité parce qu'ils ont compris ça les
protéger et que ça n'encense anna
rejoindrait pas d'origine hongroise qui
veut pas dire qu'on veut le maintenir
dans la durée
voilà combien de fois il l'a dit trois
fois il me sembla trois fois donc on a
bien compris les éléments de langage et
c'est vrai qu'ils s'appuient sur des
sondages qui sont plutôt favorables aux
pass sanitaire le dernier en date c'est
celui de doxa le 21 octobre le passé ni
terre est il une bonne mesure c'est la
question oui à 62 % 57 % en février
dernier donc on voit bien qu'il ya une
acceptabilité de la population vous
savez ça c'est un petit peu la mesure à
qui était vraiment majeur dans dessous
de cette pandémie il faut que la
population accepte les mesures pour
qu'elle soit efficace ça semble bête
hein dit comme ça mais c'est vraiment
une bataille pour le gouvernement est
donc pour l'instant ils estiment qu'ils
ont les français de leur côté avec une
partie de la population qui est peut
être petit mais qu'est l'ultra mobilisez
vous avez commencé votre discours cet
après midi
dans l'hémicycle par parler de votre
boîte mail saturé ah bah oui nous avons
je pense que vos collègues vous aussi
des milliers mais c'est passé pas
seulement déçu c'est un régulier dès
qu'il ya une loi un peu sensible on
reçoit des biens moi ça me donne
franchement je vais vous dire ça me
donne un quasi réflexe c'est d'avoir
envie de voter contre on voit bien que
cd je dirais pas des lobbys des groupes
organisés qui vous envoie d'un seul coup
c'est très très déplaisant qu'on vous
êtes quand vous êtes représentant
quand vous êtes parlementaire vous
n'êtes pas là pour céder parce qu'il ya
un lobby qui eût qui vous harcèlent
juste n'existe que quand vous recevez
dix mille mais il ya peut-être parfois
que cinq personnes ont
faim voilà c'était fait massif voilà on
va en plus si c'est poutine qui est
derrière ça me
je voudrais revenir sur cette cette idée
de d'enjamber la présidentielle et
peut-être de donner un blanc-seing un
futur président dont on ne connaît pas
l'identité est ce que ça fait partie de
vos vos autres d'inquiétude iem chantal
oui oui tout à fait c'est on sait pas
qui gouvernera sera à la tête de notre
république c'est pour ça que finalement
toutes les dispositions comprend et
quand on défend les libertés publiques
les droits du parlement c'est aussi
quelque part donné des garde-fous parce
qu'on sait pas ce qui pourrait arriver
en france vous avez vu la montée de
l'extrême droite est quand même
important il ya des gens qui ont des
discours autoritaire et pour être tout à
fait honnête un la pratique du pouvoir
telle qu'elle est et les institutions
que nous avons à l'heure actuelle
permette on le veuille ou non un pouvoir
autoritaire sans changer une seule ligne
2 de la constitution c'est un fait et ce
qu'on est favorable à ça ou non je pense
que ça il faudra aussi en débattre un la
pandémie a mis en exergue aussi beaucoup
de questions sur les libertés publiques
sur ce que ce à quoi on est prêt à
accepter ou non et je pense qu'il faudra
aussi avoir un débat important sur les
institutions comment reconnecter aussi
nos concitoyens à la prise de décision
publique c'est à dire qu'il soit
pleinement intégré dans la prise de
décision parce que ce que ce que
critiquent aussi c'est la manière d'agir
de ce gouvernement qui agit depuis le
début de la pandémie je vous le dis
franchement de manière brutale qui
infantilise nos compatriotes moi cette
histoire d'attestation les gens s'auto
attester de pouvoir sortir enfin ça
c'était hallucinant c'est franchement
c'est n'importe quoi et donc je pense
que véritablement il va falloir avoir ce
débat pour pouvoir connecter les
citoyens pour pouvoir les réintégrer
parce que toute cette séquence a extrait
miser des gens qui ne l'étaient pas
auparavant si on devait sérieux rit on
comprend vos arguments parce qu'on l'a
tous vécu aussi cet agacement de remplir
d'accord on est on est d'accord mais
quand on regarde a posteriori même si on
n'a pas beaucoup de recul tout le monde
l'accepté il n'y a pas eu de révolution
les français auraient pu descendre dans
la rue et s'opposer et la rue aurait pu
s'opposer au pouvoir qu'est ce qui les
empêche rien donc vous voyez bien qu'il
y a quand même alors certains disent
passivité mais il y a acceptation de la
part de la majorité des français
possible c'est très intéressant mais il
se pose une question sur le consentement
je suis juriste on apprend que le
consentement c'est très important et
notamment il doit pas être viciée ce
consentement quand on vous oblige à vous
vacciner parce que si si vous n'allez
pas règles par exemple faire des tests
et vous allez devoir les payer puisque à
partir du depuis 15 octobre on est
obligé de payer ces tests quand vous
devez dépenser 300 euros par mois pour
avoir le droit d'aller travailler pour
certains qui certains salariés qui sont
en contact du public c'est à peu près un
quart voire un cinquième de leur de leur
rémunération mensuelle dans ces cas là
évidemment qu'ils vont aller se faire
vacciner est ce que le consentement ne
sera pas pour autant vicier la violence
économique ça existe aussi et là c'est
clairement ce que nous fûmes
gouvernement c'est celle là vous êtes
plus du point de vue du droit mais d'un
point de vue philosophique on peut dire
aussi que peut-être que c'est un quart
exemple la même manière quand on vous
revoit les oreilles bien que la journée
en vous disant vaccinez vous vacciner
vous puisque vous êtes quelqu'un
d'égoïste et vous allez tuer des gens si
vous ne le faites pas dans quel état va
être votre consciente sentiment est ce
qu'il va être libre et éclairé c'est
aussi un principe de médecine d'ailleurs
vous êtes médecin vous le savez mieux
que moi le libre consentement du patient
aux soins doit doit être doit être
recueilli c'est pour cette raison que ce
n'est pas obligatoire la vaccination
donc vous avez vous colle pas sanitaire
est un est une vaccination obligatoire
direct qu'on le veuille ou non plein
vous l'excellent restaurant quand vous
avez quand vous dépensez 300 euros et
que vous gagnez parce que nous autour de
la table peut-être que les gens ont les
moyens mais une personne qui va gagner
1000 1500 euros j'étais devant le
conseil d'état vendredi à défendre la
fin du remboursement des tests colis
j'avais des personnes qui gagnait 1 smic
quand on leur dit vous allez dépenser
300 euros par mois pour avoir le droit
d'aller travailler
qu'est ce qu'elles font est ce qu'elles
sont vraiment libre sanitaire est
obligatoire dans le cadre de leur
travail ça te dirait
demandez pas sanitaire que claude
malhuret donc c'est un facteur de 2 de
différenciation en fonction de la classe
sociale c'est un peu ce que ce que nous
dit thibault mercier cette inégalité ces
deux points le premier c'est que
[Musique]
pendant des mois et des mois les tests
n'ont pas été payant pendant un an et
bernard un an et demi n'était lésés sont
pas des payants la france a pratiquement
été le seul pays où l'était c'était
gratuit donc c'est aujourd'hui le jour
où elle arrête en dix ans maintenant ça
suffit il ya le vaccinale il a avec son
agent et où vous il ya d'autres
solutions ont fait le reproche à la
france alors qu'on n'a pas parlé des
autres pays est désolé mais ils n'ont
pas mis lé pa sanitaire en place comme
ce test c'est pas du tout la même chose
mais il avait un pas salutaire qui vous
oblige à vous faire tester nous vacciner
pour avoir le droit de vivre et de jouir
de vos droits c'est une vaccination est
payant il devait très très lourd à
supporter pour les femmes alors que
le test gratuit pour les personnes
vaccinées dès lors qu'il est payant pour
les non vaccinés série c'est bien aussi
une incitation comme la vaccination
c'est le deuxième point que ce soit une
incitation moi je ne suis tout à fait
d'accord et je le revendique le jour où
macron au mois de juin est intervenu en
disant maintenant c'est une urgence il
faut que le monde se fassent vacciner et
on instaure le pass sanitaires c'était
évident que c'était une incitation moi
je suis pour cette association je trouve
qu'il a bien fait et les français
massivement ont dit oui il a raison
c'est le premier point le deuxième point
c'est celui là
vous dites lebas sanitaire c'est en fait
une vaccination obligatoire ce qui d'une
sorte de façon ne me choque pas et
d'ailleurs
le parti de l'âne chanterelle revendique
cet après midi au sénat la vaccination
obligatoire donc après tout c'est pas
c'est pas
quelque chose d'absolument normal la
maxi pourquoi et lyon vous l'avais dit
je suis médecin donc c'est le côté
peut-être un peu pragmatique le côté
santé publique et en santé publique et
un certain nombre de shows et un certain
nombre d'exceptions au contournement la
première exception c'est que la
vaccination obligatoire on la connaît
très bien en france il ya onze vaccins
obligatoires dans l'enfance sans
lesquels votre enfant ne rentre pas à
l'école et ça fait un siècle que ça dure
il y en avait pas à l'époque un témoin
ça fait un siècle que ça dure tout le
monde trouve ça normal il y à une
vaccination obligatoire pour l'hépatite
b dans l'est pour les personnels de
santé tout le monde personne n'a jamais
dit donc aujourd'hui on nous dirait on
n'a pas voté votre mesure mais si on
nous disait la vaccine essentiel pour
locaux vides est obligatoire en tant que
médecin en tant que médecin de santé
publique
franchement je comprend que c'est tout
sans doute une atteinte qu aucun
changement le problème et savoir comme
comme la jurisprudence du conseil d'état
le dit est-ce que c'est proportionnée
quand c'est pour eux pour abattre une
épidémie qui fait des milliers de morts
je me dis que après tout ce n'est pas si
ce qu'on est là on va rentrer un peu
dans le détail de ce qui a été proposé
et regardez au sénat cet après midi avec
alexandre poussard zoom sur l'une des
trois mesures que propose la majorité
sénatoriale c'est la limitation
territoriales effectivement thomas à ce
que propose la commission des lois du
sénat c'est une forme de passes
sanitaire territorialisée alors le
principe est simple avec ce dispositif
le gouvernement ne pourrait instaurer le
pass annie terre que dans les
départements où le taux de vaccination
de la population est inférieure à 75 %
et où il y à une circulation active du
virus c'est-à-dire un taux d'incidence
est levée alors concrètement quelle
serait la conséquence de ce pass
sanitaire territorialisées on va écouter
l'un des artisans du dispositif le
rapporteur de la commission des lois
philippe bas en 70 % des départements il
n'y aura plus de passes sanitaires en
revanche vous prenez l'exemple de la
guadeloupe de la martinique de certains
départements métropolitains aussi de la
réunion quand vous êtes à à 24 % à 30 %
même seulement à 50% de vaccination par
rapport à la population générale ça
n'est pas assez pour assurer la
protection de nos concitoyens et il faut
permettre que les outils nécessaires
soit maintenu en vigueur alors dans ce
débat certains sénateurs ne sont pas
vraiment d'accord avec ce pass
sanitaires à la carte et ils les
estiment que cela stigmatiserait
certains territoires ont écouté eliane
assassi la présidente du groupe
communiste au sénat et sénatrice de
seine saint denis je trouve que c'est
quand même une mesure assez
discriminante et assez inégalitaire
puisque effectivement on va cibler un
certain certaines populations et bien
évidemment on prend l'argument de
l'outre-mer oui on peut entendre mais il
ya aussi d'autres départements
métropolitains qui n'atteignent pas les
75% et je pense notamment aux biens et
ce ne serait pas juste je le dis avec
fermeté de stigmatiser encore une fois
sur un sujet comme celui-ci la
population la scène s'anime c'est en
tout cas ce pass and i ter
territorialisée qui est proposée par la
commission des lois du sénat au vote des
sénateurs en séance publique et bien il
a un but assumé c'est l'extinction
progressive du passani terre en fonction
de l'avancée de la vaccination c'est une
sorte d'entre deux entre les antilles
passe et la position du gouvernement
merci avec son à tout à l'heure dans
notre notre second débat yann
chanterelle
différenciation stigmatisation de
certains départements comme en voilà et
sucé à cette proposition déjà ce que
j'ai pu constater au sein de l'hémicycle
avec la majorité elle même est très
divisé la majorité sénatoriale est très
divisé sur le sujet est loin de suivre
les recommandations de de monsieur bah
nous ce qu'on propose c'est assez simple
on a rédigé un amendement avec le groupe
socialiste c'est qu'à partir et qui
effectivement que de 80% de la
population éligible qui est vacciné le
pass sanitaire saute ce qui revient
finalement à l'abolir à peu près à la
date du 15 novembre puisque c'est le cas
de tasses en métropole à ses fans en
métropole 6 d oui on est on est
favorable si on n'est pas favorable sur
la manière de l'année puis on espère que
cet amendement va être prise en compte
puisque c'est si monsieur bah défend
plutôt cette idée ils devraient ils
devraient approuver ce qui n'avait pas
l'air d'être le cas au moment où j'étais
dans l'hémicycle donc ce qui pointe une
certaine contradiction ou peut-être même
des tensions comme je vous ai dit où des
divergences au sein même de la majorité
sénatoriale mais comme je vous dis ça
reviendrait à la supprimer parce qu'à un
moment donné faut bien faut bien montrer
aussi à nos compatriotes qu'au delà d'un
certain seuil ça saute on va pouvoir en
sortir il faut pouvoir en sortir faut
pouvoir montrer le bout du tunnel donc
nous ça nous permet raisonnable de
montrer un indicateur clair qui pourrait
justement inciter à la vaccination
puisque comme ça a été très bien dit par
mon collègue au sein de mon groupe et
moi même je suis doublement vacciner
nous sommes favorables à la vaccination
de tous et quel est le meilleur moyen
pour l'atteindre et donc éventuellement
donc c'est vraiment de prendre en compte
sa pour dire aux français nous allons en
sortir collectivement en justement en
étant discipliné en permettant un
maximum de personnes de vacciner de ce
qui serait le cas si on adopté cet
amendement au 15 novembre sauf pour les
outremers bien évidemment la thibault
mercier autre réaction sur cette mesure
spécifique mais je trouve que c'est très
bien qu'on laisse un peu de liberté aux
territoires un peu de subsidiarité de
pour appliquer des mesures ciblées c'est
ce que beaucoup d'élus régionaux et
locaux avaient réclamé depuis mars 2020
déjà
et là on leur laisse en longs leur
laisserait un peu cette liberté et ces
eaux - distinguée en fonction dans
fonction de la situation ce qui est très
bien
est-ce que c'est réaliste claude
malhuret
paris et les départements limitrophes
désolé là encore de ne pas être d'accord
avec les interlocuteurs
s'étaient c'est une fausse bonne idée
elle a été testée en allemagne où les
lander où la politique s'est faite selon
les länder ça a été une usine à gaz
épouvantable ils sont revenus su ça a
été une catastrophe
et là c'est les landers et quand même
des grandes régions mais là vous allez
faire par département dans un pays où il
n'ya pas de frontières entre les
départements vous êtes à trois
kilomètres de le département vous savez
même pas quand vous êtes en voiture si
vous et vous allez selon les
départements
avoir des départements où il passa ni
terre d'autres enfin imaginez-vous il
c'est plus une question de deux théories
là c'est une question de pratique
regardez
vous avez des fêtes de la toussaint vous
allez avoir les fêtes de noël où les
gens vont partir au ski vous allez vers
des départements
qui sont des départements touristiques
et vous allez venir deux départements
qui ne sont pas soumis à passer ni terre
vous allez vous y rendez vous est soumis
au passage on a déjà ce débat sur les
stations de ski et sur les remonte
pentes ça va être une usine à gaz
complète et ça va l'être pourquoi je dis
ça parce qu'on l'a vu en allemagne donc
moi j'aimerais bien j'aimerais bien être
sur le fait que peuvent progressivement
on arrête le passenger mais je suis sûr
que ce sera une usine à gaz et
deuxièmement les critères les critères
sont absolument les critères qui sont
proposés sont pas valables le taux de
maxime deux seuls 200 critères ils sont
le taux de vaccination et le taux
d'incidence mais il ya de multiples
autres critères de ce si on veut le
différencier et qui font que les
départements que les endroits que les
zones sont soumises à des situations
différentes et il faut être beaucoup
plus flexibles et laissait notamment que
je dois les préfets ou de président de
conseil général pouvoir le décider si on
fait la territorialisation mais je crois
qu'il faut avec les critères soient ils
soient plus riez différent d'un
département à l'autre si je vous
comprends en tout cas qu'il y ait plus
de flexibilité
oui qu'il n'y ait pas de critères rigide
et puis vous pouvez avoir ces deux
critères qui sont unis et à un autre
problème qui se pose de densité par
exemple les départements sont pas d'une
vous avez beaucoup de critères qui ont
fixé pas une selon une politique de
santé publique sur deux critères rigide
mais ça c'est les limites ce n'est pas
l'essentiel je suis certain que ce sera
u que si on le faisait ce sera une usine
à gaz parce que là où on l'a fait cc
c'est une usine à gaz le plus c'est plus
est quand même beaucoup plus simple un
jour de dire
les bons c'est déjà tellement compliqué
on va re complexifier la chose qu'un
jour on décide et j'espère que je joue
sera rapide que
aujourd'hui sur tout le territoire
national il ya le passé ni terre est
bien un jour on décide il ya plus le
passé ni tête c'est clair vous êtes vous
étiez ce que vous avez dit alors pour la
vaccination obligatoire savoir est non
je je je suis pour le système actuel ça
me choquerait pas et conduite conduisait
ce qu'en fait on n'a jamais posé la
question je ne sais pas si vous auriez
été d'accord avec ça d'une vaccination
obligatoire uniquement pour les publics
qui étaient les premières victimes de
cette épidémie est ce qu'il était
possible peut être de proposer une
vaccination obligatoire pour les plus
âgés les plus de 65 ans évoqué depuis
2001 pourquoi pourquoi on n'a jamais
ciblé ces populations pourquoi c'est un
problème en france puisque nous sommes
là en train de parler de sujet un peu
tabou libertés publiques et c'est
simplement dans 7 depuis le début de
l'épidémie on ne peut pas dire ce qui
est vrai c'est que cette maladie cette
épidémie pardon ce virus touche est
vraiment mortel pour les personnes âgées
et avec des comorbidités pourquoi c'est
impossible à dire politiquement
je sais
c'est pas simplement un problème
politique il ya un problème politique
qui est que chaque fois que vous
identifier une catégorie population que
vous prenez des mesures physiques vous
avez un risque de stigmatisation un
risque de problème entre les générations
et pour les politiques c'est quand même
quelque chose qui est assez sensible
mais vous avez surtout une deuxième
raison qui est celle là une raison
technique loison je dirais presque
médical c'est que ces publics de
personnes très âgées de personnes
désocialisées etc c'est précisément ceux
qui sont le plus difficile à toucher et
que même si vous décrétez la vaccination
obligatoire
il reste
cinq ans à sans précision on n'y arrive
pas et il n'y a rien de pire que de
voter une mesure que vous n'êtes pas
capables d'appliquer qu'est ce que c'est
la sanction vous leur mettez une amende
à ces gens de nos gens extrêmement âgés
ou gens très désocialisées vous les
mettez en prison vous faites quoi un
système d'amande si on sortait plus oui
il faut aller chez nous donc mais vous
voyez y laissa personne dans les ehpad
aux personnes de 90 ans dans les états
qui vous dit je veux pas me faire
vacciner près tous laissez moi
tranquille et ô vous les faits lui met
une
tournée en d'un système démocratique on
n'arrivera jamais à faire une 1984 on
est dans un système où il y aura
toujours 10 passes en 15 ans nous
dirigerons de le seul sénateur vous nous
dites bien que le pass sanitaire c'est
la liberté c'est presque 1984 sachant
que c'est nous mettre une contrainte est
en fête avec cette contrainte nous
offrir la liberté déjà là il ya quelque
chose d'assez ja c'est malsain je trouve
j'aimerais revenir sur la vaccination
obligatoire c'est un sujet très
intéressant ce que vous nous disiez en
tant que médecin que finalement on est
déjà 11 vaccin depuis qu'on est jeune et
que ça ne se pose pas de problème donc
finalement pour en avoir un douzième une
dose de doses trois doses ce qu'on n'a
pas aussi questionné l'acceptabilité de
la troisième dose pour le bassin
sanitaire puisque les fossés sont pas
vraiment venir le sondage ses 58 au
négatif 58 des français qui
me passent sanitaires tout à fait ça
pose donc la question de la
médicalisation à outrance de nos vies
désormais on a un médecin pour sortir de
chez nous depuis le début de cette crise
il faut ce diagnostic et s'auto
diagnostiquer ce parce qu'on pourrait
peut-être être un danger pour nous même
être un danger pour les autres donc
encore une fois ça ne désarme
complètement dans notre action je vous
rappelle qu'il ya des plateaux télé ou
encore des institutions publiques qui
prennent la température des gens avant
rentré de pouvoir entrer dans ces
bâtiments ce qui est totalement illégal
et en fait on a un rôle du médecin qui
se renforce en permanence et par exemple
on a aussi justifié les mesures là
dessus il ya des médecins sur les
plateaux télé qui nous disaient oui mais
attention il ya des comorbidités cacher
ou alors il ya des kovy de long et ça ça
justifierait finalement de mettre des
restrictions sur l'ensemble de la
population plutôt que cibler les plus
âgés ou ceux qui ont des comorbidités ce
qui aurait pu être fait ce que l'état
n'a pas voulu faire par cette peur de la
discrimination alors que c'est
totalement possible par notre droit est
donc en fait on a un individu qui
maintenant est totalement dépendante
aussi bien du médecin que de l'état et
et c'est vraiment une question qu'il
faut se poser avec une pharmacie qui va
être en permanence dans nos vies et on
le voit on le voit vraiment dans cette
crise cowitz a exacerbé ce point il ya
de chanterelles c'est vrai que la vaccia
de solution obligatoire c'est s'est
porté par le par le groupe socialiste
oui oui tout à fait comme je voulais dit
on est favorable à la vaccination et
mais répondait à thibault mercier
pendant pendant combien de temps on va
devoir finalement conditionné sanitaires
parfois 12 peut-être un rappel tous les
ans etc etc ce qui est juste en tout cas
un moment donné il va falloir apprendre
à vivre aussi avec ce virus avec un
certain taux de vaccination autre va pas
pouvoir ad vitam aeternam et c'était le
début de notre échange de notre débat
accepter des mesures dérogatoires à
tintin attentatoire aux libertés
publiques de manière ad vitam aeternam
et après on fera impasse sanitaire
pourquoi d'autres c'est ça aussi la
brèche aussi une fois qu'il ya une
brèche qui est mise il ya un danger
après ça sera quoi ccc d'autres maladies
ça sera ça va être étendu à quoi d'autre
donc il faut quand même rester vigilant
vis juin sur ce point et pour en revenir
justement à cette histoire de pas
sanitaire j'ai eu même des personnes des
cas de personnes qui se relâche elle
pense être dans une zone sécurisée elles
s'embrassent alors que ça n'empêche pas
de se transmettre le virus ça n'empêche
pas également de l'attraper des doigts
d'avoir des conséquences même quand on
est vacciné il faut quand même aussi le
préciser donc finalement le pas
sanitaire des fois amené aussi des
personnes à se relâcher c'est le
paradoxe mais c'est un fait donc rester
vigilant et protégée au plus près les
personnes et ça a été très bien dit
qu'ils sont les plus vulnérables je
pense que notre politique publique doit
être ciblé le plus possible vie vie des
personnes qui sont les plus vulnérables
effectivement qu'ils ont sont le plus à
risque d'en mourir ça a été très bien
cité est plutôt que d'imposer une mesure
est un régime d'exception permanent à
tout le monde je pense que ça ce serait
la meilleure chose alors sur la
souplesse qu'on peut éventuellement
apporter à ce passe anitea vous pouvez
écouter le sénateur lr philippe bas il
propose d'appliquer des contraintes qui
sont proportionnées notamment en
fonction de nos lieux de loisirs ont
l'écoutent dans les départements les
plus vaccinée on pourra encore demandé
le pass sanitaires pour les restaurants
les cafés les discothèques
la vraie question c'est est-ce que je
dois retirer mon masque ou pas
partout où je peux garder mon masque
comme dans une salle de cinéma n'est pas
indispensable de mettre en plus le pass
sanitaire
mais partout où je ne peux pas mettre de
masque parce que je vais consommer par
exemple ou parce que je vais me trouver
dans une situation de très grande
promiscuité
avec un exercice sportif ou la danse
là il faut maintenir le pass mais
uniquement dans les départements où on
n'est pas suffisamment vacciner voilà
pour avoir à peu près les différentes
propositions qu'on avait de l'animation
immédiat côté j'ai tout à l'heure de l'
usine à gaz c'est compliqué vélib
lui-même qui propose la mesure de
territorialisation vient de nous
expliquer que dans certains départements
où ces critères sont remplis où on a le
dos de vaccination on pourrait si j'ai
bien compris continuer à garder deux
passes sanitaire dans un certain nombre
de situations lesquels je veux dire on
voit bien que c'est les promoteurs même
de la mesure ce ne sont pas capables de
nous expliquer que si c'est clair aussi
visiblement pas claire pour lui-même
moi en vous écoutant la pendant tout ce
débat on arrive vraiment à la fin j'ai
le sentiment on dissout dans la société
française depuis des décennies on n'a
plus de projet collectif est ce que
finalement ça n'a pas été un projet
collectif la vaccination et le succès de
la vaccination si beau merci
voilà c
je ne pense pas je pense au contraire
que c'est un individuel dans
l'acceptation dans l'acceptation par la
société française c'est un
individualisme exacerbé notamment un
individualisme exacerbé par la peur et
par la contrainte du gouvernement qui
nous infantiliser dans sa communication
depuis un an et demi notamment olivier
ferrand je vois qui culpabilise et même
les députés dans l'hémicycle mais
acceptait de se vacciner pour sauver
aussi les autres il s'en explique c'est
ce qu'on nous a dit mais
regardera la majorité c'est la majorité
des français ce sont 26 la parole s'il
vous plaît
permettait de retrouver la liberté en
même temps ça leur permettait de
retrouver la liberté ils ne sont pas
beaucoup de français ne se sont pas
vaccinés pour des raisons sanitaires ils
se sont vaccinés pour pouvoir aller en
vacances ou pour pouvoir vivre
normalement et pour pouvoir protéger
leurs grands comptes mais certains
évidemment mais en tout cas pas tous et
je ne pense pas que ce soit un projet
collectif
ma question vous surprend elle aussi non
mais en même temps c'est vrai que il
faut reconnaître que nos compatriotes
ont été exemplaires dont la pandémie je
n'en dirais pas autant du gouvernement
comme vous avez dit que des mesures très
brutale et infantilisante vis-à-vis de
nos compatriotes mais malgré tout je
pense qu'il faut penser parce qu'il ya
une partie de la population qui ne
souhaite pas se vacciner comme je
voulais dis moi c'est un sujet
d'inquiétude quand même pour moi parce
que j'ai pu le constater je pense que
tout le monde peut constater des proches
ou autre ça a divisés quand même
beaucoup les familles et ce sujet la
divise beaucoup sein même des familles
autres et moi c'est mon inquiétude c'est
qu'il ya des personnes qui ne sont pas
radicaliser au départ se radicalise
s'enferme parce qu'elles n'ont plus
accès à la vie sociale et ça on les met
en marge de fait et ça c'est quand même
un point d'inquiétude important est
qu'il ne faut pas ignorer qu'il faut
quand même prendre en compte de ne pas
laisser des gens sont là non plus les
surestimer sur estimé leur nombre à mon
avis merci beaucoup merci tous les trois
d'avoir participé à ce débat on passe